it's rush hour in Delhi which means a
daily battle on the city's roads cars
took trucks buses even animals jostle
for every inch of space hopelessly
clogged roads and bumper to bumper
traffic driving here is not for the
faint-hearted it is totally chaotic and
everybody drives as per word say he
thinks the road belongs to him he has
the first right and a pedestrian doesn't
have any right awake buses took took
scars cycles motorbikes they all drive
in the same lane it's all haphazard and
crazy it's also a major headache for the
city's overstretched traffic police
force now see that that cart is going
that's going with his own space how can
you have a lane discipline in such a
situation because it is moving Mukesh
under is Delhi's traffic police chief
he's trying to do the impossible
managing the traffic in a city of more
than 16 million people
delhi is also home to india's most
dangerous roads many drivers in the
capital care little about traffic rules
and are undeterred by the often
negligible finds driving against the
traffic jumping a red light blocking
intersections they're all commonplace
the Delhi police are now turning to
residents for help with a mobile app
called traffic Sentinel it's monitored
here in the control room citizens can
use it to upload images of drivers
breaking the law who are later
prosecuted users earn points for the
offences the record and can even win a
car a motorbike or air tickets it will
fill a play role in two ways one that
the traffic Sentinel himself will be
cautious that if he is trying to catch
others he also need to obey the traffic
law and then anyone who is committing
violation would fear that there is
somebody who is watching him somewhere
who can shoot a photograph of a
videograph video which will be in
clinching evidence of traffic violation
the app has about 900 users so far
people like my uncle he heads to a busy
intersection and photographs person
driving without a helmet one click and
the image is uploaded via the app the
software engineer who lives in east
delhi thinks the app is a good way for
volunteers like himself to help the
police do their job I think it has
become like kind of a heroic to break
the laws people feel like more macho by
breaking the law it seems the tackling
Delhi's daredevil Road attitudes may
require more than an app to bring them
in line but filming offenders can also
be risky in a city notorious for road
rage and aggressive drivers and the app
does little to change underlying
attitudes towards safety and responsible
driving